so you see the increase in lawlessness
when we take God out of everything so
we're so far down the concern you am on
that and I'm talking about the fact that
if you stay in a hotel anywhere you
can't even find a Bible in the
nightstand anymore now admittedly the
Bible is on it's expensive but it's just
a thing that
isn't that amazing so I have to admit I
am partially to blame for their not
being as many bibles in hotel hotel
nightstands anymore when I go into a
hotel
when I look in the nightstand if there
is a Bible there I put it out in the
hallway like your room service tray that
you're done with I take it I don't want
it in the room I admit that I do this
now sometimes I'll put it in the
recycling bin but I my instinct is that
the housekeeping staff probably takes it
out and puts it back in the nightstand I
don't know but my move is to take the
Bible and to put it in the hallway and
then it disappears I just don't want it
in the room with me